oh god i remember what what year did uh
chris transition
2014 i believe right right yeah and it
is a very disturbing uh phase yeah
that's what i want to like what's up
there's a lot of stuff that chris
does and later christine they're very
like worrying i'd say right well that
happened a lot a lot what's what's the
line of worrying
i've already heard a lot of boring
things this episode
so how did it start
we know that well how does that all ever
begin uh with chris
yeah transitioning yeah um
chris very early on exhibited some
interest in in being a female
um like for example writing on uh on
public posts in a troll created forum
which which which was made to appear
like a fan site for christian but
they're all just trolls yeah
of course um chris said that
sometimes they thought that maybe life
would have been better if they were born
as a female but
since i was born with but since like god
delivered this package i must like feel
it i don't know
something like that yeah chris chris had
a lot more more poetic than i do yeah
well of course of course
um then chris started leaking some some
uh chris was sending nude photos to
other other girlfriends
which i featured
chris trying on their mother's
on underwear bra as well right so that's
i was worrying as well yeah yeah and
then after and then after that uh
another
e-girlfriend convinced chris that maybe
they would feel better jogging because
they were very self-conscious about
their man boobs bouncing around so so
she suggested maybe chris should wear a
sports bra and then chris discovered
that they really liked the feeling of a
sports bra
and um pretty much never took it off
after that point honestly until until
they transitioned and started wearing
you know women's underwear full time
right right it's like um some people
suggest that maybe chris was influenced
by trolls saying
some some quotes exactly that uh chris
was convinced to become a female to
explore their feminine side right um
this is questionable no no one's really
sure how this happened but um yeah chris
started first identifying as like a
lesbian soul in male body something like
that okay right i'm not very well
educated on this stuff it's very uh i
try to but it is it's quite a lot of
information yeah yeah
and after after about another half year
or so they they've they fully embraced
the identity of of the new name
christine
and uh changed their uh gender
officially even under a driver's license
so it's so it's quite quite legit at
this point yeah and they do use uh
gender transitioning medication as well
okay right right yeah i i say concerning
because during the first phase it was
very much a diy uh transition that
wasn't the first phase actually that was
you know it was quite a bit after it was
it oh yeah i felt like that because that
was what stuck out to me what goes
before diy
well chris chris decided to uh expedite
matters by by listening first by by
listening to binaural beats on youtube
what is binaural beats i still don't
know what that is binaural beats is a
type of like a humming noise that's
that's supposed to that's supposed to
influence the way your mind works and
kind of change you in a certain way like
for example it uses like a it uses like
a certain frequency i believe that it
almost acts as like a type of hypnosis
right of sorts is it a lot of is it
[ __ ] is it
there is actually science behind is this
a well-known thing this is the first i'm
hearing this no this is very much like a
music like is it really a real thing i
mean there is some science behind it but
like but the whole thing of like
hypnosis and stuff like that is very
debatable i mean binaural beats making
you like feel uncomfortable or
comfortable yeah i i can see that
happening but changing you from male
organs to females sexual organs
chris was trying yeah chris was trying
to grow boobs boobs and then chris was
actually going to the actual uh channel
of these bunnell beats and and asking
the uploader will this will this
binaural beats video cause my testicles
to develop into ovaries or or would they
make another video about that or uh
no
that's very sad because in some aspects
this is where other aspects of the
internet failed chris right like this is
this is a predatory thing to and i don't
know if they encouraged or they said
that yeah you'll grow boobs from
listening to this beat
that's [ __ ] but and also when you're
desperate enough as i imagine uh chris
was at the time
you'd be willing to believe it i mean
i'm sure chris has fallen for more
obvious stuff with like because this was
after the yeah
right and uh didn't chris end up in
hospital uh for trying to uh
so this is a very disturbing
thing um
they believed uh that the
uh
opposite sex organs were inside all they
had to do was cut it
open
and they did indeed do that right and
they ended up in hospital um what they
what they cut
was the uh was the space
in in between the uh the douche
right i i believe that's yeah
i believe that's the way to call it yes
i think it's called the gooch i think
it's called the gucci
gucci
gucci skin between the balls on the
bottom right yeah they're they're
they're good that one pretty deep cut
right they cut
the the
perimeter not educated on this i don't
touch that place often
it is the premium also called the taint
the taint of the paint so that's the bit
that's the space between the whole and
i'm so sorry viewers i'm so sorry we're
using scientific terms here yeah chris
believed that in this space was where
their labia would be if they were born
as a woman so they so they cut it open
and posted photos
they posted photos oh yes
what wait of after the act like after
they come out it must look like a crime
scene
jesus looks fine to me i don't know
you're poor man
i've seen worse i can't tell if gino if
you've been broken by all of this you're
just you're so dis you've been so numb
to it for so long like a war veteran now
yeah like this this is murder do you
know what sound a man makes when they
die i do
and i like it
they went to hospital for it right they
were very reluctant to go to the
hospital because they were infected
right
it could have been it was it was like
they died
yeah from what i understand it was very
worrying
it could have like yeah no [ __ ] because
i caught like abscess or something and
died from it eventually but yeah
eventually trolls convinced chris to go
to the hospital and get it checked oh
the trolls convinced chris to go to the
hospital which is weird because then
later on i'd say from this point onwards
is where it used to be like kind of like
a almost torture hostage situation yeah
i was like i want to talk to you but i
want to keep you alive yeah yeah yeah
because a lot of the trolls and i
believe the uh especially what happened
a little later on as the founding member
of the kiwi farms right often would
financially look after chris
and would help manage chris's finances
right wasn't it wasn't there like later
there was like a group of people right
people would offer they didn't go fund
me correct after the the uh
the watchmen or something was that what
they thought the watchman is a different
thing
this is insane
so these people who had originally were
trolling chris ended up then
supporting him supporting chris and
almost being protective over who can
have contact with right chris right
yes yes they were yeah it's weird right
because it feels like a hostage thing
yeah it's like i'm gonna feed you food
and take care of you but you're still my
hostage right like the weirdest cult
i've ever heard it's very strange yeah
the thing is is after after chris's
father died the main trolls behind all
that kind of stopped their trolling and
then uh moved on to kiwi farms just like
as an observation kind of thing and
looking after chris but like the other
trolling that happened after that point
was made by other people which were not
affiliated really with the with the
original core because then there's like
tons of different factions of right
people who are obsessed with yes